monday edition of pftpm let's get right
into it what happens first miles first
category who gets traded first
carson wentz
russell wilson deshawn watson who goes
first
i feel like you're making me play a game
of merry you know murder or whatever the
third thing is there yeah
yeah whatever the third thing is
yeah whatever
carson wentz though
right because carson woods i think is
the only one of these guys that's really
immediately about to get traded so i
think when you look at it you know we
obviously know the rumors that he was
supposedly supposed to be traded last
week after the super bowl i remember
that was the reporting and then
obviously that did not happen and it's
apparently because the eagles haven't
been offered enough uh in terms of a
trade offer quite yet so i would say
that uh wince probably gets traded first
then desean watson and i don't see
russell wilson getting traded i don't
see why they would trade him because i
don't think the the relationship between
the seahawks and russell wilson is
irreparable like i think it is with
desean watson mike somebody in the
industry who likes to stir a little crap
from time to time texted me a screenshot
of espn this morning and it said at the
bottom eagles expected to trade carson
wentz in the coming days
chris mortensen and adam shafter report
and the question posed to me was what's
the record for most consecutive days
that a trade is expected in the coming
days but it's it's been expected in the
coming days for the past 10 to 15 days
look i i think i think the reality is
and i agree with you i think wence is
the first one to go
and march 19 is the practical deadline
unless the eagles want to pay wentz a 10
million roster bonus and then say to the
colts or whoever the suitor is we want
more we want 10 million in draft pick
value for the money we've paid this guy
because now you only have to pay him
30 million over the next two years not
40 million
i i i doubt that the eagles are going to
do that i don't think jeffrey laurie
wants to cut a check to carson wentz for
10 million i think it gets done by the
19th and i think right now they're just
waiting for someone to come out of the
weeds it's a deadline driven business
there's no reason to come out of the
weeds now there's no sense that a deal
is is happening momentarily with the
colts i feel like the colts are the only
real destination two second round picks
is what ron jaworski said the colts have
offered
i don't know why wentz would want to go
to the bears i don't know why the bears
would want wentz peter king and i argued
about that this morning if i'm wince i
want nothing to do with chicago because
that fan base is just a half of a click
below philly from the standpoint of how
upset they're going to be if when stinks
at least indianapolis he'd be patient or
it wouldn't be obvious that he stinks
because the offense is already pretty
good the defense is already pretty good
it's a better team it's a better
situation to walk into i think he wants
to go to indy i think the colts want him
but the colts know they can wait but i
think it comes to a head before either
of the other two situations are ready
for a deal to be reached between new
team and current team
yeah and i think the fact that wence
should want to go to indianapolis is
really the only destination at least off
the top of my head that would seem to
make sense for him i mean he's very
familiar with frank reich is there press
taylor is now there so
that from that standpoint it's like all
right these are guys that i know and
guys that i trust and guys who i think
can really get the best out of me and
that's got to be really important to him
i think you know anybody's got pride as
a qb you've got to have some pride in
order to get out there and compete and
try to compete at a high level and if
carson wins has that then he's going to
want to go to a situation where he's
going to be set up the best in order to
succeed and frankly based on the way he
played in 2020 where he took 50 sacks
and led the league even though he didn't
play a 15 a 16 game season
i don't know why anybody else would
really want him i don't know why anybody
else would say yeah i'll give you more
than two first-round picks for this guy
he's not shown that he can play at a
level recently enough that's gonna tell
you look yeah i have a lot of confidence
that he can get back to his 2017 level i
just i don't know why you would do that
acquiring him on the hope that 2020 was
an aberration is not the best way to go
about filling your quarterback position
next topic jets trade sam darnold or the
nfl draft what happens first that's an
interesting one because it just makes me
think about the arizona cardinals a
couple years ago and what they ended up
doing with josh rosen which was keep him
until they picked kylo murray at one and
then they still got a second round pick
form and i mean now that we've seen josh
rosen's career unfold over the last
couple of years it kind of seems like
the arizona cardinals got back the best
value they could ever possibly get back
for josh rosen i think that sam darnold
could maybe command the first round pick
i don't know that i would trade a first
round pick for him but if i'm you know
20 or lower and i might need a qb then
that's something that i would consider
doing but i don't know that that means
that donald's gonna get drafted or
excuse me get traded before the draft
because i don't know when his value is
exactly going to be highest i mean i
guess it is right now before that uh
before the draft happens if the jets do
take a qb but if they don't then he's
still going to have some value mike
but you know you've identified a third
category the sweet spot between the
start of the draft and the start of
round two on the second day of the draft
that's that opportunity to work out a
deal for darnold if the jets take a
quarterback with the second overall pick
and if there's a team out there that was
evaluating the possibility of taking a
quarterback didn't but still has a need
at the position and wants to bring in
sam darnold that one intrigues me the
other thing too is you just let the dust
settle on the draft and then after the
draft
if a team isn't happy with its
quarterback position or maybe a team
that was kind of bluffing its way
through the draft you know i look at the
49ers i think they'd they'd surely like
to trade jimmy garoppolo if they're
going to move on not cut him but if you
can't find a trade partner for jimmy
garoppolo cutting him becomes a viable
option you're looking at 25 million or
thereabouts that you're going to pay a
guy that can't stay healthy maybe after
the draft
if you don't draft a quarterback
you trade for sam darnold and you say
see you later jimmy garoppolo in one
fell swoop so there's a lot of different
ways that that one could go and that one
intrigues me because i'm not going to
commit to one or the other and maybe
you're right maybe it happens during all
right last one real quick what happens
first jj watts signs with the team or
free agency officially begins
yeah i wish that this were the the cap
officially gets set because i think that
is when
we're gonna see more movement on jj watt
when we know what the cap is gonna be if
it actually is gonna be at 180 million
if it's gonna be a little bit higher
than that or maybe a little bit below
that then i think we'll start to see
more movement on jj watt because at that
point teams are gonna know what they can
actually offer him mike and i think
before they know what they can offer him
it's gonna be really hard to sign a
veteran guy like that
yeah i agree with you unless he decides
to go to one of the teams that has the
cap space that they can go ahead and
jump i think he's more motivated by
playing where he wants to play than
grabbing as much money as he can at this
point but we'll see how that plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports